[Music]
throughout the first half of 2018 the
European Parliament led a series of
debates on the future of Europe with EU
leaders from migration and climate
change to growth and security eight
leaders have come to Parliament to share
their views on the challenges facing the
bloc one of these challenges is the UK's
decision to leave the EU Parliament
plays a key role in negotiating the
withdrawal agreement in March members
called for joint commitments on citizens
rights financial obligations and the
Irish border in continued efforts
towards a stronger digital economy
Parliament voted to end barriers to
cross-border online shopping and
approved a draft law to facilitate the
free flow of non personal data
strengthening the rights of posted
workers members voted on new rules to
ensure workers who were sent temporarily
to other EU countries get the same pay
for the same work
the aim is to improve their travel and
accommodation conditions and establish
fair competition for companies at least
35% that's how much energy should stem
from renewable sources members also set
objectives like the use of smart
technologies and the energy-efficient
renovation of buildings as part of the
fight against climate change the e used
carbon trading system was updated to cut
greenhouse gas emissions by at least 40
percent and further curb co2 emissions
from industry while encouraging
low-carbon investment Parliament set new
targets to boost recycling cut landfill
and prevent waste through better
packaging in its efforts to move towards
a resource efficient society the new
rules also aim to reduce food waste in
the EU by Harvey members call for a
sustainable farm policy to be integrated
into the circular economy fostering
innovation research and smart practices
they urged fairness in distributing
funds to farmers and called for
increased support for beekeepers
[Music]